regardez ce que j'ai pour vous c'est les
nouveaux JBL tous one m2 on se parle les
6 du casque le plus haut de gamme de JBL
qui vient de t'annoncer et qui est très
cool 299 € pour se faire plaisir il est
très confortable ça c'est bien mes
lunettes donc là on est vachement bien
on se parle ici d'un casque avec
réduction de bruit on a également
l'ambiance de centre qui vous permet
d'entendre tout ce qui passe autour de
vous on a ici du Bluetooth 5.3 et puis
bien évidemment le Fast paire de Google
LE SON spatial JBL 4 micros 4 micros qui
vont servir pourquoi pour les appels
c'est bien mais surtout pour la
réduction de bruit active on va jusqu'à
50 heures au niveau de l'autonomie en 10
minutes de recharge vous prenez 5 heures
d'autonomie compatible Amazon Alexa
Google assistant iOS mais bien
évidemment Android et on s'en doutera
ici on a du irez audio et ça c'est bien
pour moi c'est vraiment aujourd'hui une
découverte je trouve sympa mignon il
vient se plier alors on peut faire même
un peu de sport avec vous voyez il est
très léger confortable donc si ça vous
intéresse je viens de découvrir ce joli
casque et bien allez jeter un coup d’œil
chez JBL personnellement je trouve cool
comment est-ce que vous trouvez ce
nouveau tour one m2 bien pas bien dites
le moi dans les commentaires